when Ben Atkins grandfather died he and
his mother Anne found a novel way to
include everyone in a celebration of his
life Ben got family and friends isolated
in their own homes to perform the same
anthem then he dubbed them together to
create an orchestra and choir
head teacher and musician David Briggs
died at 102 only four of his family were
at his cremation a traditional funeral
has been postponed the emotions that I
experienced upon completing this project
was exactly how I would have expected to
feel after the funeral it was a real
testimony to to quite how much my
grandfather meant to so many people but
also it was a testimony that you know
we're not gonna be beaten by this thing
what we did was completely different
from what we'd always envisaged my
father had planned his funeral really
meticulously and this was totally
different but it was everything we could
do under the circumstances and that felt
very fitting and very right and enough
it felt really fulfilling
under the new coronavirus law attendance
at funerals is restricted to close
family only friends are barred unless
there is no family virus deaths
accelerate funerals may have to go ahead
much quicker without even relatives
present if they themselves are ill or
self isolating the reality is reflected
in more temporary more cherries this one
almost completed in London which is
seeing a third of the UK's deaths at a
former US Air Base in Oxfordshire
aircraft hangars are being converted
into more thérèse the storage will be
basic there are 10 hangars each with
room for 600 bodies Oxfordshire County
Council said they will be used only if
required
writer Anakin's wrote the words for this
anthem her musician son Ben arranged the
traditional tune they hope others will
use it as an inspiration to find their
own way around a lonely funeral
[Music]